I'm breaking the law, Manny. What the Manny, Manny, I'M BREAKING
THE LAW. WHY YOU FAT POSTING, BRO? >> I'm just trying to
control what you say >> I am bought it, yes. I am bought
it. I am yes. I My views aren't even real. I write nouns on a
board and people believe me. What the Manny >> And I'm
not professor. I'm not professor. But but I never said I was
professor. It's the internet who called me professor. >> Hold
on. You don't call yourself professor. There ain't no way, bro.
Yes. 42 X's coming in clutch. I forgot this happened and I wanted
to watch it. Manny Hassan versus Professor Jiang. Let's [__]
go. >> you China's Nostradamus.
That's what I wanted to Oh my god, you saved the stream. Let's
go. >> famous predictions in 2024 that Trump would get
elected, that he would start a war with Iran, and that he would
lose a war with Iran. Iran clearly has the strategic strategic
advantage. I think the next step in the escalation ladder is
that Trump will send in ground forces. Manny Hassan says that
Nikki Haley was key to your prediction about Iran. You said Trump
would pick her as his running mate, but he didn't pick >> I
think that the problem with education is that it focuses too
much on facts, too much on Manny Hassan >> calling education
is like half asleep. >> is that it focuses too much on
too much
>> He's like he's like kind of He's kind of just like glazing
over and then it will come up instantly. I think the problem
with education is it focuses way too much on facts. He's like,
"Huh?" And not enough on imagination. >> Do you hear yourself?
Just trying to control what you say now. >> Your critics
might say, "They're using you as a >> got no problem with
that. It's possible. I'm useful >> No worries for me at
all. >> And I suspect that there are many entities around
the world who would like to amplify my message, including the
Chinese government. >> Hold on. Hold on. You don't call
yourself Professor Jiang on your YouTube channel. I do now, but
when I first started out, if you go way back to my >> when
you first started out. You do call yourself Professor Jiang and
you're not a professor. What is your big prediction now for 2026?
We'll see what happens. We can test it out at the end of the
year. I hope Manny Why why would you care about this semaphore?
Like nobody cares about this one. This one's obviously wrong
for him. And I just I super don't care about it. I I literally
don't care. As far as I'm concerned, you could claim 100% of
women sell their ass on OnlyFans and I still wouldn't give a
I literally All discussions of this kind of thing, I literally
couldn't care less about all the time, every time. It's like
so not important to me to argue over. I don't give a
Back in 2024, Chinese Canadian educator Xue Chen Jiang posted
a video on his YouTube channel, Predictive History, where he
laid out three big predictions. Donald Trump would win the 2024
election. The US would then go to war with Iran, and ultimately
the US would lose that war. Since then, the self-styled professor
who says he uses game theory to analyze the past and predict
future geopolitical events has become an internet sensation and
has even been dubbed China's Nostradamus.
But he's also faced some criticisms over his predictions and
many would say pretty out-there conspiracy theories. Two out
of three of Jiang's big predictions have come true. But how much
of that is his own geopolitical foresight? How much does the
Chinese government control or even influence what he says, what
he predicts? I decided to not just speak to Xue Chen Jiang, aka
Professor Jiang, about Iran and the state of the world, but also
to challenge him a bit. Here's our interview.
Xue Chen Jiang, thank you so much for joining me on the show.
Um you have said you use game theory to predict future geopolitical
events. For those who have never heard of game theory, please
do explain what it is and how it helps you explain what's happening
with Donald Trump and with Iran in particular. Uh-oh. Uh-oh.
Cuz when Professor Jiang says game theory, he basically just
means I'm going to tell a story that I think is I'm going to
give you a just-so story, right? That's what he means.
And I'm guessing that Manny knows like the like the dictionary
definition of game theory, right? And he's probably going to
push back. Or or this guy's going to give the dictionary definition
and this guy's going to Then Manny's going to say, "Well, how
does that apply to this analysis?" Let's go. >> Right.
So, game theory applied to geopolitics
means that we see each individual nation-state as a player in
a zero-sum game to maximize
um its uh individual interests.
And so, each player would have its own characteristics, its own
strengths, and it would adopt a optimal strategy in order to
win the zero-sum game. So, how does that apply in the Middle
East right now?
Right. So, um the United States is
That's just realism. It is just realism, >> attacking Iran.
And these two nation-states have different strengths and weaknesses.
So, America has um the world's greatest military. It has air
supremacy. It It has tremendous technology. Um it has unlimited
funding. And so, Iran is adopting an asymmetrical
>> Unlimited golden eggs. holding the global economy hostage,
meaning that rather than attacking the United States directly,
which it cannot defeat directly, it's in instead
uh controlling Strait of Hormuz, which is strangling the global
economy, and it's attacking the GCC nations
the infrastructure of the GCC nations in order to force Trump
into the negotiating table. So, that is the asymmetrical warfare
of Iran. Uh you've also predicted that the US You had three famous
predictions in 2024 that Trump would get elected, that he would
start a war with Iran, and that he would lose a war with Iran.
Based on what you've seen over the past month, do you still stand
by that prediction?
Yes, I do. Um I think that Zeteo is entertaining this guy? Come
on, man. No, no, no, no, no, no. You don't understand, marmadude.
In fact, Manny Hassan is pushing back on this guy. He's actually
going to
He's not going to let this guy just run with whatever
Cuz Manny Hassan is awesome. We love Manny Hassan. >> I
think that um Iran clearly has the strategic strategic advantage.
What I mean by that is that Iran is very clearly able to articulate
its uh military objectives and has a very clear strategy of how
to obtain these military objectives. And it is working uh very
hard and very meticulously to obtain these objectives. This is
the complete opposite of America, where Trump has failed to articulate
an end goal. Um and right now, it seems that the administration
the Trump administration
um is unable to articulate both a strategy and a purpose to the
American public, which is causing
um most Americans to not support this war. It's also causing
low uh soldier morale among the American forces.
What do you think happens next if  when Iran wins? Right.
So, um even though Iran has the advantage right now, we still
remember that America is the world's greatest empire and has
a lot of resources and has a lot of firepower still not used.
>> The So,
why? Why? Why? Why?
Somebody Somebody said Oh, somebody's saying like Why would you
say Somebody said Iran has the advantage. It's like Yeah, Iran
does have the advantage right now. I'm not sure if people were
doubting that, but they do actually have the advantage right
now. I don't I don't think that's um
I don't think that's wrong by any measure, okay? I think that's
like obviously true that Iran has the advantage. It's not that
they have the advantage in like a true military sense, right?
In terms of what they had when they went to the table, like when
they In terms of what they had to try to win some engagement
here and what their opponent had and then what both sides have
to lose, they are coming out ahead in terms of their objectives,
right?
Just keep in mind that like probably what should happen in this
case is total American victory without any losses. That's like
That's the bar America has to reach, right? That's the expected
outcome for America. You America is expected to go and deal with
this lesser power with zero blemishes. That's the That's the
record they had in Iraq was they basically couldn't have [__]
up militarily, right?
But that is not what's actually going to happen and that's not
what's been happening. And the economy is getting totally [__]
because of it, which is again to Iran's advantage. That America
basically Trump ran on not doing that. Trump ran on, "Hey, I
know the last couple of years have been economically tough, but
we're going to make it better for you guys, okay?" And then he
was like, "Actually, [__] you." >> I think
the next step in the escalation ladder is that Trump will send
in ground forces. So, over 5,000 Marines uh and soldiers have
been dispatched to the Middle East. This is already on top of
the 50,000 American soldiers already stationed in the Middle
East. And most military analysts expect that um uh the Americans
will launch an amphibious assault in order to control the Strait
of Hormuz. Now, there are several options available to the Americans
um in order to control the Strait of Hormuz. Uh the first option
is to control Kharg Island, which is the oil depot of the Iranians.
90% of Iranians oil exports um depart from Kharg Island.
Then you have Qeshm Island, which is opposite the
Strait of Hormuz. And then there's a naval base uh further down
the coastline. And so, these are the three options uh that the
Americans have. And it is unclear which option the Americans
will ultimately choose, um but given the track record of the
Marines, we can expect uh the Marines to have an early success.
The problem with the strategy and the problem with America's
overall strategy is what happens next. How do you maintain control
over the territory that you've claimed? The reality is that the
Iranians have I've preparing this battle for about 20 years.
They developed this um very effective asymmetrical warfare strategy
of using drones and ballistic missiles from afar,
hidden in underground bases to
uh hit and strike American assets around the Middle East. This
is almost like guerrilla warfare. And historically
um a What do you mean it's almost like guerrilla warfare? It
literally is guerrilla warfare. >> Guerrilla power has
had great difficulties in containing guerrilla warfare. So, unfortunately,
the Americans don't have a long-term strategy of how to win this
war. Trump is still hoping for a quick strike, a knockout punch,
and he believes that the American Marines can deliver this knockout
punch.
have made a lot of predictions.
Some have called you China's Nostradamus.
How would you respond to those who say, "Sure, you guessed that
Trump would win in 2024 and he'd go to war with Iran, but that
wasn't based on geopolitical insights or game theory." People
who follow American politics or world politics could have guessed
that. I think I and many others were warning that Trump could
win in 2024 and that he would escalate with Iran as he did in
his first term when he killed Qassem Soleimani. Right. So, I
think that if you've been following the news very
then it was actually pretty straightforward to make these three
predictions, right? Because in Trump's first term, as you mentioned,
Trump did have a history of escalating
Oh, Matty. Dude, he basically just gave it away, right? Actually,
if you just paid any amount of attention, it's pretty easy to
make these calls,
to be honest with you. Like actually, if you just paid any amount
of attention at all, well, Trump's basically a 50/50 chance to
win the election. And from there, it's like a 90% chance he goes
to war with Iran.
bingo bango. Pretty easy, Matty. conflict with Iran.
So,
the biggest
escalation was when Trump ordered the assassination of Qassem
Qassem Soleimani. And quite frankly, America and Iran should
have gone to war during that that time. But because of the escalation
efforts on both sides, we prevented World War III during that
time. But Trump was under tremendous pressure from his allies
and from his donors to start a conflict in the Middle East. So,
if Trump had um had won a second term, then he would have started
the conflict. I was pretty confident that he would start the
conflict if he had won in 2020.
But unfortunately, he lost. And so, my question then was, what
is the likelihood that he would get a second term? Would he win
in 2024?
And then, as I watched the news, it seemed
pretty obvious to me that the Democrats
were hopeless, that they didn't that that they were not delivering
on the promises, that there were a lot of issues. For example,
what was happening in Gaza, the war in Ukraine, that was making
American voters
with the Democratic establishment.
And so, I thought that Trump would have a very good chance of
winning 2024.
And if he if he won in 2024, then I think there's a But he didn't
pick her. And his current vice president, J.D. Vance, is widely
seen as a skeptic of this war. So, you'll admit you got that
wrong.
What the [__] pretty straightforward to make these
three So, if Trump had um had won a second term, then he would
have started the conflict. I was pretty confident that he would
start the conflict if he had won in 2020.
But unfortunately, he lost. And so, my question then was, what
is the likelihood that he would get a second term? Would he win
in 2024?
And then, as I watched the news, it seemed
pretty obvious to me that the Democrats
were hopeless, that they didn't that that they were not delivering
on the promises, that there were a lot of issues. For example,
what was happening in Gaza, the war in Ukraine, that was making
American voters
with the Democratic
And so, I thought that Trump would have a very good chance of
winning 2024. And if he if he won in 2024, then I think there's
a very strong likelihood that he would attack Iran. And so, all
three predictions have panned out. Just on your predictions,
I just want to be clear. Nikki Haley was key to your prediction
about Iran. You said Trump would pick her as his running mate
and as vice president, she would pressure Trump into war with
Iran. She's a notorious hawk. But he didn't pick her. And his
current vice president, J.D. Vance, is widely seen as a skeptic
of this war. So, you'll admit you got that Yes, absolutely. So,
so I was thinking of what Trump's electoral strategy would be
in 2024. And I think that if he picked Nikki Haley, there would
be a tremendous boost to his campaign because Nikki Haley would
be very popular among the old Why? That's like a totally That's
totally analysis.
That's absolutely terrible analysis. Not that J.D. Vance is a
lot better,
but but like the Nikki Haley thing, that's awful analysis.
Oh, Trump should like get the the neocons to come vote for The
neocons were always going to vote for him. The neo- The neocons
were never ever a contingent that he had to go and try to They
are totally spineless,
totally servile losers who will vote for any Republican. Of course
they were always going to vote for him. That's what they did
every other election. He's got to try to go for other other demographics.
Now, in terms of electoralism, if he's going to pick a VP because
he wants somebody who's electorally viable, who helps him electorally.
Now, he picked a different VP entirely,
right? But then he just picked one who agreed with him. conflict
in Washington, D.C. She would also be very popular among suburban
white women. That was key to Biden's victory in 2020.
So, I made the prediction that he would pick Nikki Haley. But
at the same time, um Um dude,
minus Mitt and the Cheneys, Mitt is not a neocon, I don't think.
I don't think Mitt is accurately described as a neocon. He's
like something else.
I I think his political positions are not that of a neocon, right?
But for everyone else, for for the Cheneys in general, yeah,
I Dude, I bet you I bet you Cheney went there and held his nose
and voted for Trump anyway. I bet you. I bet you. I wasn't completely
sure about it because I also felt that J.D. Vance also had a
good opportunity to be
selected. And I also said during my lecture, make the prediction
that Nikki Haley would be his running mate, that depending on
whether or not In 2016, I mean, obviously. Nikki Haley or J.D.
Vance, this would determine how we can foresee or understand
Trump's second term. And so, if he had picked Nikki Haley, then
he would have been completely full He would He would have been
fully committed into the neocon project of regime change throughout
the Middle East, of supporting Israel, of establishing American
imperial power throughout the world. He didn't pick Nikki Haley.
Instead, he picked the complete opposite, who is J.D. Vance,
who has who is America First, who has always been skeptical
of American imperial overreach.
But not only that, but he also picked Tulsi Gabbard to be his
director of national intelligence. And so, these are the two
major skeptics of this war in the Middle East. And what I will
say about picking these two individuals is that it shows that
Trump has an off-ramp strategy. Where if this if this war goes
sideways and and American public is up in arms and he's losing
in the polls, then Trump may decide to pivot back to America
First and have J.D. Vance and Tulsi Gabbard elevated in the administration
over individuals such as Marco Rubio and Peter Hoekstra. What?
Okay. I
Where does he elevate J.D. Vance to,
Where Where do you elevate J.D. Vance
In that administration. As far as I know, there's only one person
above J.D. Vance in that administration. And so, that Yeah. I
suspect he will blame Pete Hoekstra if all of this goes sideways,
as it is. Where does China fall into all of this? You're a Chinese-Canadian,
you're based in Beijing. China clearly stands to gain from a
failed U.S. war with Iran. How many How much of your views are
reflective of China's views? The Chinese government's views?
The CCP's views? Right. So, the official Chinese
Communist Party line is that China is committed to global peace
and to global trade that benefits all.
China wants a win-win global system in which people are trading
peacefully and which everyone is committed to world
>> The true art of war is not in
the fighting, but in the stopping. Okay? That's what we That's
what we know about >> And so, China has come out vocally
criticizing both Iran and the United States. United States was
starting this war, but also Iran for attacking the GCC energy
infrastructure. Remember that
China relies heavily on Qatar liquefied natural gas, as as is
the case with other countries in Europe. So, China looks at what's
happening in the Middle East, and China I think is working very
hard diplomatically to come to an agreement. Unfortunately, right
now, China doesn't have much leverage over either the United
States or Iran. In fact, many analysts believe that this war
was started in part to economic sanctions Dude, I think the fact
that we're not seeing clips anymore, I'm like very spooked about
what's going on with this war. I can't be the only one. I'm not
seeing any clips of strikes, and yet somehow all the power's
out in Tehran. Where are the clips at? Where do I WHERE AM I
SEEING I'M NOT SEEING POWER plants being struck. I saw clips
of everything. Now I'm not seeing clips of anything.
What the [__] And then I get news yesterday that
the power's out in Tehran.
And then I I also saw, but I haven't confirmed, that Iran struck
a Oh, they [__] They They struck a distillation plant,
like a essentially desalination facility. They don't have internet?
Then how the [__] were they uploading clips before
when they didn't have internet? They equally didn't have internet
before and now. They were using Starlink.
strangle China. Because China depends on a lot of its economy
Oh, sorry. A lot of its economy is based on
accessing cheap energy from overseas, especially the GCC. China
imports 40% of its energy needs from the GCC. And so, if the
GCC were to stop energy production, then China's economy would
be in a lot of trouble. And this would give Trump a lot of negotiating
leverage over China in the upcoming talks scheduled for mid-May.
And I and I believe that what's going to happen is that because
the Chinese are extremely pragmatic and very business-orientated,
then I think that um Trump and China will sign a landmark
Oh, Ken Klippenstein posted a week ago that the American government
is pressuring satellite companies to censor uh deal where China
agrees to buy a lot of energy from North America.
You're full of praise for China's role in trying to get peace
in the Middle East. Uh here's what I don't get. You were caught
filming protests by Chinese workers famously in 2002 as a freelance
journalist at the time. Uh you were suspected by the Chinese
government of spying. You were deported from China. Reporters
Without Borders protested your deportation at the time. How did
you get back into China? And why is it some of your critics say
you have so little to say about China's role uh in all of this
geopolitics? Is it because
>> I get where Medhi's coming from.
But like does that is that self-explanatory?
I feel like that might be self-explanatory, no? I understand
that he wants to go to China or whatever, but that that could
be literally hey, you were like filming stuff. You were like
uh shilling for Chinese protest before.
Uh I'm assuming that's what they they felt, right? And then he's
kicked out. It's like yeah, I don't comment on China anymore
cuz last time I did, I got kicked out. It sucked. >> Because
you're not allowed to currently? Right. So, um when I started
out as a young journalist, um I was on contract by by PBS to
do a documentary on China's WTO entry. And one major issue about
China's um WTO entry, of course, is worker rights. And at this
time in China, there was a major restructuring of the state-owned
enterprise system. So, I was dispatched to northeastern China
to film a worker protest. Unfortunately, the place was swimming
with um police spies. And I was arrested and interrogated for
2 days. I was held in coming in new new new new NATO for 48 hours,
which is the maximum um um by Chinese law. And um I signed a
confession saying that I was a reporter and working in China
illegally as a reporter. And the decision was made to deport
me without charging me with um any crime. And so, I was allowed
to come back in the country, but I was deported. Um so, that
was the story. >> If they suspected you of being a spy,
how did they let you back in? China's not known for being that
trusting.
>> They suspected me of being a spy, but after a 48-hour
investigation, after um uh doing a thorough background check
on me, they concluded that I was not a spy. And I I was a journalist
um um working to film in a in a a worker protest. But it wasn't
just 2002. In 2017, we checked
I think Medhi is implying that he's working for China now. I
feel like there was there was a little bit there to the possible
like American government spy
stuff, right? I think there was like a little bit to that. >> an
op-ed for cnn.com headline China's media enables tyranny and
corruption. In that piece, you praised the US media as the world's
free speech defender of last resort. You said in China, power
trumps truth. And China's Communist Party, you said, maintains
its iron grip on power by controlling what's said in the media
and what's taught in the classroom. Do you stand by those views
from less than a decade ago?
Um so, in 2017, when I was asked by CNN to write an op-ed, um
I did stand by those views at that time because um like everyone
else in 2016, when Donald Trump won the election, I thought this
would be very bad for uh American democracy because he was clearly
not a believer in free speech. He called the news media uh fake
news. And so, I wrote the op-ed for American audience saying
like the greatest treasure um the greatest wealth of America
is the First Amendment, the right to speak whatever you want.
And I conscious conscious that with China, where you you're not
allowed to say whatever you want, where you are very much monitored
uh by uh the government. Um even today, I do not have a Chinese
online media presence. I do not say anything online. I do not
talk to reporters in from China because I'm conscious that whatever
I say online could be used against me. >> But hold on.
They allow you to be on this show. They allow you to be on YouTube.
You get past the Great Firewall that you criticized in that CNN
piece. How come? Hm. Look, the reality is that the best way to
unders-
I'm always suspicious when somebody
doesn't even wait for you to finish asking the question
and they start answering and it's not like a direct answer to
the question. The second you ask that right? And he like doesn't
answer
you say Medhi cooking.
At minimum, I doubt he would answer these questions honestly
to begin with cuz he works in China. Like he or he lives in China
with his family.
That like even if let's say he did actually believe all those
things still I feel like he's probably super careful about going
after China. He might he might be a Chinese asset at this point.
It's possible. But like if he wasn't, then he would also answer
the same way. So, I feel like I'm trying to think of what questions
would be dispositive
for me. Like which questions would sorry, a proof positive maybe
is what I Which questions would actually show that he is a Chinese
spy? stand my situation in China is I'm essentially a Martian
on Earth talking to Martians back at home in Mars. Like I'm not
part of the Chinese system. I'm on YouTube, which is blocked
in China. I I How do they allow you to be on YouTube? This is
what I'm not understanding. If you're blocked in China, why do
they allow you to be You're very prominent now. You're famous
in the West. I'm sure the Chinese government has noticed that.
Well, most Chinese um will have access to a VPN device. And that's
what I use in order to um access Listen. I'm breaking the law,
Medhi. What the Med- Medhi, I'M BREAKING THE LAW. WHY YOU FAN
POSTING, BRO? Why you fan posting, dog?
You wrote for CNN that the Chinese government has built a Great
Firewall to monitor and control their citizens' pursuit of truth.
Um does China control what you say now?
China does not control what I say because again, I'm not talking
to Chinese people. I'm talking to >> Hold on. No, that's
that's what most people would say is China's great benefit. They
might see your critics might say they're using you
Oh, this So, this depends on
this depends on like how you look at it. If you are very much
like somebody who believes the Chinese government and like their
core ideals
this could make sense.
I don't necessarily believe that. I do believe China's greater
aspirations for the first time in a long time. But if you do
believe that they all they want to do is look within they might
they could feasibly from that exact perspective
say something along the lines of
well, as long as you're not doing propaganda in our country,
we don't give a [__] Propagandize outside of our
country all you want. Just don't propagandize in our country,
right?
It's it's possible that he's like cool with that or sorry, that
the CCP is cool with that as long as he's not giving his views
to Chinese people, sending his views to Chinese people. That
they don't care about his comments on China or as long as he
does as long as he colors within the lines on China. Right? That's
like you'd you'd have to believe that core premise that China
doesn't care to look outward. They only care about the like what
the internal workings of I just don't believe that personally.
But if you did believe that, it would be
like possibly.
Uh Brian, those are good questions. How does he declare his income?
Like what does he say he does? Like clearly, he's got an agreement
with the Chinese government that this is fine. Now, why would
that be, right? He is extremely famous. He makes a lot of money.
And he does so by circumventing the law
That implies something's going on there. He has some kind of
agreement. Why is that allowed? Um does China control what you
say now?
China does not control what I say because again, I'm not talking
to Chinese people. I'm talking to >> Hold on. No, that's
that's what most people would say is China's great benefit. They
might see your critics might say they're using you as a propagandist
to come and say this stuff about Iran and US on behalf of China.
That would be what your critics would Look, the reality is that
this is a fair and legitimate criticism that I've been contemplating
for the past three, four weeks. Because you know, when I first
started this YouTube channel like 2 years ago, I was expecting
5,000
uh No, you're you're right, actually. You're right. I I could
be a Chinese shill. I I've been thinking about it and it makes
sense that I would be like a Chinese shill. I'd be like a Chinese
spy. who would have a passion for learning, who would be as engaged
with literature and geopolitics as I was. And over the past month,
I've blown up across the internet. And I don't think this is
organic. But But so, I wonder
And I don't think this is organic?
Wait, who's doing it then?
I am boughted. Yes, I am boughted. I am yes, I my views aren't
even real. I don't think this is legitimate. I listen to what
I say. It's I write nouns on a board and people believe me. What
the man? This can't be organic. I'm Why are people listening
to me? if there >> some governments or some entities that
believe that my message should be amplified. Um It it is it is
possible I'm a useful idiot. And I suspect that there are many
entities around the world who like to employ my message, including
Chinese government, but also including the Russian government,
including some aspects of American government, including um some
some some people who are hostile towards war. I appreciate your
candor. You said you blew up on the internet. Uh you did go viral
over your Iran predictions. But on your YouTube page, as people
now start to acquaint themselves with you and familiarize with
your work, uh people have been slightly surprised to see some
of your other stuff. You have a series of lectures focused on
secret societies where you argue that groups like the Illuminati,
the Freemasons, the Jesuits are at the center of world control.
People would say you sound kind of crazy when you talk about
the Illuminati. It's the kind of thing you hear in Dan Brown
Right. So, I'm trying a new approach to pedagogy and to scholarship,
which is speculative uh which is speculative analysis. So, um
I went to Yale and I received a very rigorous classical education.
I'm very happy and proud that I went to Yale. But what I discovered
in life um as I stumble through life is that what I what I was
taught at Yale doesn't really apply to uh real life. People with
the most rational, logical arguments don't usually win. And people
who are most aggressive, most unlikely aren't usually the ones
in power. So, I was determined uh just for my own personal benefit
to develop a new system which He discovered grifting from first
principles. There ain't no way, bro. I discovered grifting from
first principles. I noticed that telling the truth and like playing
by the rules really didn't help. And so, I've discovered a new
concept that I've come up with. I'm bringing it back to China.
We were unfamiliar with this. It's the concept of lying
and making things up that sound compelling, but probably aren't
under the surface. Uh have you thought about this, Medhi? That
like if you just if you just didn't concern yourself about what
about the
have you thought about this at at Medhi? So, it can insight into
how power works in the world. And so, I started um something
called predictive history. And the very idea of predictive history
is this, how do we know if our understanding of history is correct?
And the answer is, well, we can make predictions based on our
on our historical framework. And using and seeing these predictions
work out or not uh validate our historical models. So, what I
discovered is that if you have a That's not That's not true,
by the way. This is the concept of um Uh the best example I I
know of this or the one I like to use is basically like you can
know for sure that lightning is going to strike a tree during
a storm, a very tall tree, right? And
>> it doesn't matter what your reasoning is for it. You're
not validating your reasoning because the lightning hits the
tree. Like a lot of older, you know, if you go back to like um
ancient Ice- not Iceland uh ancient, let's say, Sweden. They
might say lightning strikes the tallest tree because Thor hates
that things are daring to be as tall as he
And that will you to predict what's going to happen in the world
very well. But, it is not effective reasoning. It is not actually
well reasoned from first principles at all. There's nothing to
You're not making any like axiomatic declaration You're not doing
anything to build some sort of proof that this is why it happens.
You have some totally babel-based belief
and it happens to work out, right? So, so when he says this,
he when he says like, well, it validates when your predictions
come true, it validates your framework. No, it doesn't.
Repetition, being able to repeat it reliably, validates your
framework.
You just making predictions and then one of them happens to come
true. It does not validate your framework at all.
of game theory, um historical patterning, and eschatology, then
this gives you a pretty deep insight into how the world will
turn out. And secret societies are very much an important aspect
of eschatology. I'll come back to secret societies. Couple of
things you mentioned there. Uh you said uh you were Yale. Uh
just to be clear, your degree was in English literature, was
it not at Yale? It wasn't Yes. International relations or national
security. You're an English lit graduate. And you're not a professor.
I know it's your YouTube moniker, but you're a high school teacher.
You're not actually a professor. [clears throat] Right. So, um
I when I went to Yale, I was actually a math and physics major.
I was a declared math and physics major, but the Yale English
department was very strong, and so I switched majors. Uh so,
I both I've actually both a math background as well as an English
background. Uh that's why my uh system of analysis can can seem
strange to people because because I'm combining a multi-disciplinary
approach to my thinking. Um
And I'm not a professor. I'm not a professor. But, but I never
said I was a professor. It's the internet who called me a professor.
>> Hold on. You don't call yourself [laughter] professor.
I'm not I'm not a professor. The internet called the my called
me a
Wait, don't you call yourself Professor
But, it's on the internet. Dude, he he literally discovered lying
from first principles. It's awesome. He He's Instead of lying,
he is using like
he's using the fact that people like compelling things.
Right? They like to be They like to hear things from a compelling
figure. And so, I've decided that using the moniker of this,
it's like people like to hear things from an authority figure.
So, I found out if I called myself an authority figure, if I
implied I was
then then
people listen to me more. It's like, yeah, that's lying. Again,
it's lying.
He's lying about a math major? Well, he didn't say he was a math
major. He said he declared a math major and that he has a background
in math, not that he has a math major. What happened probably
is he went he declared himself a math major before he'd actually
taken before he finished his like general studies, he'd probably
switched over to English, right? >> Sir, I'm not a professor.
But, but I never said I was a professor. It's the internet who
called me a professor. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. You don't call
yourself Professor Jiang on your YouTube channel. I do now, but
when I first started out, if you go way back to my early days.
It doesn't matter when you first started out. You do call yourself
Professor Jiang, and you're not a professor. Look, look, there's
a guy on the internet called who calls out who calls himself
the god. Have you interviewed him yet? Um and ask him why he
calls himself the god. I think
Dude, I actually can see exactly where he was going. He is quite
literally Dude, he's he's literally
going to argue that it's actually smart to lie. And have you
considered this, Medhi, that it's like it's actually way easier
if you just lie? >> I I I'm I'm good friends with the uh
radio host called Charlamagne the God, but no one actually thinks
he's a god. People actually think you're a professor. Just sticking
with your analysis. You just said speculative analysis. To many
people, that sounds like you're just making it up. You're
Look, I I think that
He He is Yeah. education is that it focuses too much on facts,
too much on rigor. And I'm not saying imagination. >> facts.
Do you hear yourself? It sounds >> You said I mean, what
do you mean too much on facts? Look, look, I I I I know this
is going to sound strange, but there is a difference between
facts and truth, right? Facts are what can be independently verified
by other sources. Truth is a deep understanding of the world
that allows you to understand why things are the way they are
as well as well as make certain predictions. We used to be a
people a human species that was very focused on truth-seeking.
Uh and and that's why religion was so such an important part
of our lives because um God um prayer was was very important
to help us understand um our place in the world, uh where we
came from, what we're doing here, and where we're going. And
now, we just focus on facts, on making sure that you're you can
memorize the all the elements of the periodic table, on um making
sure that you are >> about When you talk about secret societies,
I guess people would say, well, where's the factual evidence?
Where's the evidence You said I think the Jesuits control the
Vatican. First of all, there's nothing wrong with Jesuits. Good
people. I know many of them. Second of all, there's only ever
been one pope who's a Jesuit, and he's gone. So, people would
wonder like facts are important to your evidence. And people
would say that it's not just fun and games when you're doing
speculation on YouTube. Uh they look at some of your rhetoric,
and they see that you don't just criticize Zionism or Israel
as many people legitimately do. You talk about this pretty far-right
concept of Pax Judaica, a new world order centered around Israel.
You have a video called Dawn of the Jews in which you seek to
answer the question, why is it that Jews are so dominant? Surely
you understand why a lot of people think at best you're trafficking
in pretty anti-Semitic tropes, and at worst, you're a card-carrying
anti-Semite when they see that stuff. Okay, well, that is a very
strong accusation. So, can you please tell me uh what specifically
I've said that you find offensive?
When you do a video called Dawn of the Jews, why is it that Jews
are so dominant? You don't find that offensive? I never said
Jews were dominant. What I said in my lecture was that the Danny
was created by the Persian Empire in order to better control
the Levant. And if you read the Bible, that's exactly what what
you can derive from it. If you go to my lecture, Dawn of the
Jews, you will see that I used the Bible as my primary source,
and then I analyzed what the Bible was saying. Now, the problem
is that most people don't read the Bible. The people who came
up with Pax Judaica are not biblical scholars. They're the modern
white supremacist far So, I So, what is wrong with the term Pax
Judaica? You tell me. What does it mean? It just means that um
this that um there is an entity in the Middle East um Israel
that is able to dominate the Middle East very much along the
lines of Pax Americana um and Pax Britannica and Pax Americana.
>> You said Pax Judaica. That implies all Jews. You know
the tropes about
Oh, no.
>> Oh, I think Medhi's actually up here.
Pax Judaica would literally just mean Judea. It would just mean
Judea, which is a region.
I think you're actually up on this one. Pax Judaica just means
the region, bro. >> Who's running the world? I wouldn't
be okay if you said if Iran is dominant, Saudi Arabia is dominant,
Pax Muslimica. In fact, you know that there are many racists
in the West who do believe that Islam and Muslims are trying
to take over the world. I find that equally offensive. Right.
So, um so, I'm using a Latin convention. And so, Latin convention
would be Pax Judaica. It would not be Pax Israelica. I mean,
it it I mean, like Do you know where this concept comes from?
It exists in far-right online circles. It's not Or maybe does
does Professor Jiang not even know that? I mean, I don't like
what Medhi's doing cuz I know Medhi would talk about Greater
Israel.
And I don't see a large difference between Pax Judaica and Greater
Israel. I think I think if you read it as well, it's it's as
the ethnicity or even maybe the
maybe
you could find it offensive. But, I I just thought I assumed
it was Judea. Pax Judaica comes from Judea, the Latin
Judea is what it was called when Rome was an empire.
Pax Romana is literally
where this comes from, again.
I don't know. I I made I thought none of this weird that that
Medhi just brought up. But, maybe Pax Judaica is like a white
supremacist term that's used in that way a lot. It's not some
academic term. Do you believe that the Greater Israel project
is a far-right conspiracy theory? None. What What is it then?
I think it's a very real project being carried out by the Israeli
government. I just don't call it Pax Judaica. Right. Okay. So,
the difference between the Greater Israel project and Pax Judaica
is this. Greater Israel project is what uh Uh-oh. Uh-oh. Uh-oh.
Mr.
Mr. Jiang's making my argument. Uh-oh. Pax Judaica, Latin for
peace, is a hypothetical future period of peace in the Middle
East based on Israeli regional hegemony. Modeled on Pax Romana
and Pax Americana. It is gaining traction in contemporary geopolitical
and eschatol- eschatological This Dude, this is made after Professor
Jiang said
International studies influencer Jiang
uses Pax Judaica to describe the shift where Israel replaces
the United States as the primary power in the Middle East. The
framework suggests Israel will maintain regional stability through
advanced surveillance, AI, and strategic lever- leverage rather
than traditional military occupation. Endorsed the idea of Pax
Judaica and has stated that Israel has the biblical right to
Greater Israel from the Nile to the Euphrates.
Pax Khazarica. Okay. Okay, dude. Okay,
This seems to be like mostly The term was coined in the '90s
to mean Jews,
Where is that here?
In the work of scholars like Sheikh Imran Hussein, Pax Judaica
represents the third and final stage of the global order and
precursor to the appearance of the Antichrist. I I don't see
this as offensive, but maybe he stumbled onto something that
could be considered
>> believe that Yahweh, their god, promised to their ancestor
Abraham in the Bible. And this extends from the um uh Nile to
the Euphrates. And I could have just used Greater Israel project,
but I want to differentiate um because I believe that Pax Judaica
is not an empire run by for by Jews. It is an empire run by transnational
capital and Jewish societies in order to create an AI surveillance
state throughout the the Middle East. And they actually listen
Just to be clear, uh this is speculative analysis. This is not
based on facts, as you say. So, it is it is based on speculative
analysis, based on history, historical patterns. It's also based
on connecting the dots. Because if you just look at what Netanyahu
says, if you actually just go and watch on YouTube >> Well,
I know what Netanyahu says. I We're in agreement on how bad Netanyahu
is, how expansionist he is. I'm talking about the language you
use, the milieu you're in. Let me ask you this before we wrap
up. What are your own politics? Where do you place yourself on
the political spectrum?
I believe I've always been on the left. Um um so, I I believe
that wealth redistribution is very important. I believe in freedom
of speech. I I am anti-war. I'm anti-empire. I believe in individual
autonomy. Um and so, unfortunately, I used to be left, but I
think like like given my uh preferences and given my politics,
I believe most people would consider me on the far right nowadays.
And that's unfortunate.
That is unfortunate. Last question, uh you made three very famous
predictions in 2024. What is your big prediction now for 2026?
We'll see what happens. We can test it out at the end of the
year. Well, I've made three predictions about how this war will
progress, okay? So, my first prediction is that the United States
will use ground troops. And and and and I believe that this ground
troops will be a quagmire for the United States and that they
will have to call up a national draft, okay? That's my first
prediction. My second prediction, and this is very important,
is that Israel and the United States will not use a nuclear weapon
in this war. I think that the talk of nuclear weapons is fear-mongering.
I don't think we'll escalate to that point of nuclear >> you're
right. I worry about nukes. I hope you're right. And my third
and most controversial prediction is that I believe that during
the course of this war some Uh wait, he said draft? Yes. Now,
I wonder if he's going to bring up the point cuz what he said,
I don't want him to get away from this. He said all of the Arab
nations were going to come together as one to push back against
the Americans. And I've seen no indication
that the other Arab nations, the other Gulf nations, are going
to do that. I He said that was going to happen. I don't know
if that's going to happen. And he made that prediction.
So, I hope I hope this last one is going to be that prediction
and he doesn't run away from that. >> Worry about nukes.
I hope you're right. And my third and most controversial prediction
is that I believe that during the course of this war, somehow,
someway, uh the Al-Aqsa Mosque will be destroyed. Wow. Um yeah.
Well, that would be a disaster. Um God forbid. Uh we will have
to leave it there on that rather dark prediction. Dude, all he's
doing literally all he's doing
is taking like the
he's just taking the like um the doomsday stuff, right? The evangelical
doomsday stuff and saying that it'll happen. Which, I mean
so many people needed to happen for their beliefs and to continue
supporting Israel. I'm not I'm not shocked that he makes these
predictions. It does feel sometimes like
it is just going to happen.
What, you linking me to Iran? But you so we come secret society
hashtag end Pax Judaica.
Well, that's cool. Okay, we're done with the Mehdi Hasan and
Professor Jyang
And I think we're actually done with the stream here. I think
the stream is over.
Thank you guys so much for being here tonight. I will be back
tomorrow. I'm going to try I'll see if I can go and find some
more information to to put together some of this JD Vance stuff
cuz I I do think it's actually important.
So, I'm going to be interested to see if we could if we could
figure that out. Figure out some more examples. Cuz I think I
think JD Vance has got to go down for this. At least with people
who are like nationalists who like the America First stuff, like
the JD Vance's sort of ruled himself out.
Yeah, anyway.
Yeah, anyway. I thought Mehdi would go harder, but oh well. Mehdi
goes pretty
Professor Professor Jyang literally when when he's called out,
he just goes, "Yeah, you're kind of right. I do just make this
up. Yeah, you're kind of right. Like, this wasn't very a very
special prediction. Yeah, you're kind of right. I could be a
a Chinese shill. I could be a Chinese spy."
Like, what are you supposed to do when when you're like, "I'm
going to make a damning allegation."
And he's like, "Yeah, you're right. That That would make sense."
"I could be a Chinese spy, actually."
The only one he didn't he didn't like let go was, "I think you're
an anti-Semite. You might be an anti-Semite." He's like, "What
the No.
"No. Okay. Yeah, I could be a useful idiot. I could be a useful
idiot. I don't think my growth has been organic at all. What
a guy. What a guy."
Okay. All right. That's it. We're done. That's it for the stream.
I'll see you guys tomorrow, okay? Have a good night. Bye. Bye.
Bye. Bye. Bye.
Good night.